hi buzzfeed i'm addison wright and i
play paget sawyer i'm tanner buchanan
and i play cameron kweller in our movie
he's all that so today we will be taking
the co-star test with buzzfeed i think
we're both needing some good luck
[Music]
all right here we go all right their
favorite snack at craft services i feel
like you got this one you know what this
one is like coffee yup yeah and it's
like not really a snack snack but like
you literally drink that all the time i
feel like that's just like a go-to that
is a go-to your favorite snack i feel
like you always snacked on different
things all the time there was something
that i got all the time tea
yes yes cheese
i'm not a coffee girl i'm a tea girl
healthy guy yep i'm checking that one i
am too that was good that was actually
that's really good okay their dressing
room must-have this is like coffee once
again like i feel like you just need
that but like was there something
specific you even asked for is there
shots i'm kidding
i'm joking i'm joking i'm joking no i've
never done this i've never asked for
anything in my dressing room ever yeah
nothing and i was gonna say nothing for
you i know we both had nothing in our
trailers but i feel like it's because we
spent a lot of time not in our trip
exactly like we always were like always
either together in like the main area or
like we all would be just on set yeah
most times yeah i'm gonna say we got
that one right too
you're right me too because we have
nothing okay a go-to activity between
filming scenes
i'm gonna say yours is either drinking
coffee or
you would like go back and like
highlight your lines that'd be like the
thing you would do he would like
rehearse before we'd go back and film
another scene and like highlight his
stuff which is like a pro tip that i now
use because of you and it was really
good just to like get into the character
in the scene beforehand that's right i
would say your go-to activity crafty
or
sometimes because you had extremely long
days compared to anybody else or taking
a nap possibly i would definitely take a
nap whenever i could i for sure would i
say we got that right too their favorite
netflix show i'm literally just gonna
say cobra guy but i know that's just not
true
i mean you're in it so that's like it's
hard to be your favorite but like okay
i'm gonna take a wild guess okay
manifest you know what i've not watched
it yet so i don't i can't say that that
would be it i'm really into you because
i like penn badgley as an actor a lot
that's a good one i'm gonna take a wild
gate get a case i'm gonna take a wild
game
manifest
oh how random no i literally watched one
episode of it so that's not my favorite
netflix show my favorite netflix show i
feel like also you like i loved that
show and i liked the cast a lot all
right well we didn't get that one right
we're wrong their favorite 90s rom-com
okay i'm gonna guess i'm gonna guess i'm
gonna say she's all that that's what i'm
doing yeah that one's like like the
clear winner there
yeah i'll guess yours ten things i hate
about you that's exactly yep yeah that's
another
i'd probably say the same thing for you
so she's all that and 10 things i hate
about you i feel like those are the
markers of that was good perfect 90s
wrong times
the last project they worked on before
filming
yep okay i got that i would just have to
say your music possibly because i
remember you started to show me some of
the stuff while we were even while we
were filming i got to hear some of her
music before anybody else has true
you've actually heard so many songs that
aren't out yet well i only have one song
out but you've heard songs that aren't
gonna come out for like a good minute or
maybe even never so like unreleased
music it's really good
that's your favorite song obsessed
addison right yeah so we both got that
one right yes their favorite scene
you've shot together while filming he's
all at i'm gonna say yours is the
horseback riding the stable i'm guessing
which specific one the one where i threw
poop in it okay i think that's your
favorite one that's that wasn't my
favorite one okay you're right really
any scene riding the horses yeah we'll
get a half a point for that one yeah i'm
gonna count a half a point first time
you met we know this one it's the
backyard of one of our producer jennifer
uh that is where we met okay check mark
there their birth year i know this one
like 98 yeah yeah you're 2000. yeah i'll
do quick maths in my head same their
birthday
i know you're a sagittarius and your
birthday was when we were on set yes
exact date i don't know december
oh my gosh stop november
it's december
september i'm kidding it's definitely
december december 6th 7th december 9
10 8.
thank you guys
yours is i know what day it is is
because that was the second time we met
because we went to go over the script
with director mark waters and i remember
i got you a little crystal
to protect you and bring creativeness
while we were shooting so that would be
that would be october 6th yeah that was
one of the nicest gifts i've ever got
actually it was just really thoughtful i
still have it in my i have like a memory
box that i keep like everything in and i
like i just never want to like lose or
get rid of and this isn't oh that's like
a really nice gift their hometown i
don't know your hometown balls i know is
louisiana i'll go home stay that so much
i say louisiana all the time and also i
lived in so many different places
growing up i literally don't remember
what state you're from atlanta no
georgia
i'm saying that because you you were
there for cobra guys so much i feel like
that was the only place i ever knew you
it is like a second home literally no
hometown is ottawa ohio oh my gosh i
knew that oh that makes me so much only
reason i know i knew that is because
remember i brought up the paul brothers
whenever you told me you're from ohio
yes yep i knew that wow i wasn't
thinking their social media account
handle yours is tanner became an
official yeah yeah that one's i think
yours is just addison ray wrong
what is it
oh
that was wrong i have two e's my last
name starts with an e so addison right e
yeah i got that right he's gonna say i
didn't get that one right their middle
name you should get this right is it
right yes
my middle name is ray i don't know i
never asked you your name emmanuel
emmanuel e m m
n
for what reason
don't know mom
their coffee order hot yeah black
hot and black that's exactly what it
would be mine i i do have a coffee order
you do
i clearly drinking
can someone turn that couple i can't i
won't be able to read it from here even
it's probably an iced coffee
or would it be a cold brew
it'd probably be iced cold brew yes is
that a thing with vanilla
and
some sort of milky product
would it happen to be um
[Music]
oats milk
wow
yes okay nailed it yes so i got a
vanilla sweet cream cold brew their
hidden talent okay this one i feel like
we just talked about so the whistle he
can whistle oh
we did talk about it with the whole
tongue thing and i think
but i'm trying to think if there's any
other hidden talents that you might have
i have a couple in my head not much
anymore but i used to practice magic all
the time really like magic tricks and
everything oh my gosh i love that i have
hundreds of decks of cards and just
different magic gags and all kinds of
stuff that's like a fun fact it's a
really fun fact i want to know how to do
more magic i know one trick
[Music]
we tied we know each other the same i
was actually pleasantly surprised by the
ones you didn't know good times
fun times thank you so much buzzfeed for
having us i think we knew each other
better than we thought we did yeah don't
forget to watch use all that on netflix
on august 27th
thank you buzzfeed thanks see ya
[Music]
you